دعاء الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في تغريده
له على تويتر لعلم امريكيين الى التصويت
في الانتخابات النصفيه وغرد بايضا قائلا
انه يوم الانتخابات اجعلوا اصواتكم مسموعه
وفي ما يتجه ملايين الامريكيين الى مراكز
التصويت للاقتراع في الانتخابات النصفيه
اعلنتها السلطات في مقاطعه ماري كوبا
بولايه اريزونا التي تشهد منى
تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه قبل فتح صناديق
الاقتراح حضر المسؤولون في المقاطعه من ان
السلطات المحليه لديها سياسه 09:00 تجاه
كل من يحاول ترهيب الناخبين تشهد هذه
الولايه كوبا عفوا هذه المنطقه التي يفوق
عدد سكانها اربعه ملايين نسمه تشتى والترا
متزايده منذ انتخابات عام 2020 بسبب اعلان
الحزب الجمهوري ده عدم ثقته بنظام
الاقتراع فيها
[موسيقى]